number nine car and your program number
one in your heart from Chip Ganassi
Racing in the Honda team Scott Dixon
here on the Rich Eisen show how you
doing Scott I'm doing fantastic thank
Sam you know do you do you remember do
you remember Chris Brockman
changing your tire Scott I mean I know
your champion right now and I know
you've got a lot of accomplishments in
your career but do you remember when
class change your tire Scott it was a
little while ago right it took like a
really long time or something and you
just want the championship in Sonoma
right so congratulations to you Scott
Congrats
it was so into the season but you know
fantastic for the team and and number
five sounds good sounds a lot but in the
number four that pretty happy with that
one yeah and you just needed a cruise to
it how differently do you race when you
just have to cruise Scott to victory
there wasn't really you know and then
you know automatically it you know your
your mind kicks into okay they're going
to go off strategy Australian is going
to work you know they're going to come
back and and sweat strategies you know
what's with the stops to go and be
leading the field so it's at that point
you you know you start questioning a lot
of the decisions they make as a team and
strategy and and just you know where
it's going to finish up but luckily
enough we you know we kept a pretty cool
heads you know Rossi did you know a
fantastic job to come back through the
field and and you know get with and you
know so the top seven or top eight cars
but yeah it worked out very smoothly
and not what we kind of expected now you
won ahead of Dario Franchitti in terms
of most IndyCar Series championship
since 96 it's your your your fifth in 15
years 15 years ago you won your first
what would the 2018 Scott Dixon tell the
2003 champion Scott Dixon I don't know I
enjoyed that one pretty good I think I
think I ride the way away from that one
you know pretty well but I don't know I
think you know all of us through our
careers you know we learned from many
different things but I think you know
those are paramount and you know how
they change your career and how you
changed you know the process of what you
do and you know mistakes are meant to
happen and and you know for me it's it's
definitely helped so I don't know I I
remember
those days emember them clearly it was
nice to be a little a little more
carefree back then yeah I feel like the
stress is a lot higher now and you know
there may be the you know situation of
you know we should get it done a lot
more often so I don't know I finally
there's a lot more pressure these days
and for me I enjoyed it back then and
you're the subject of a Universal
Pictures doc called born racer coming
out on October 2nd DVD and Digital
Download so is that are you a born racer
Scott Dixon I was a born racer very much
so it's yeah excited for that you know
Universal did a fantastic job it was
pretty much normal of last season and
you know we kept it off well I think was
hopefully we can add a bit of an
addition with her at the end of this
year but you know they're their capture
of you know their horrific accident we
had last year at the 500 but a lot of
behind the scenes access that you need
to get to see and you know for a lot of
general people you know they you know
almost think that you take the car after
truck you turn the key start it and away
you go whereas you know there's 80 to
100 people just behind two cars that you
know make this process happen and the
emotions that everybody goes through so
I'm excited for I think it's a fantastic
IndyCar racing and for moderation works
well and then when you win in Sonoma I
mean what a great spot to celebrate
right dude are you a red wine or white
wine here are you are you either one of
those Scott yes I go I go for effect so
you know that it's work but no it's it's
it's fantastic you know Sonoma and
especially for the sponsors and family
and partners you know it's definitely a
great spot to put on the last event
unfortunately it was our last one there
at Sonoma it moves to Monterey to you
know for next season only going to Seco
so it'd be interesting but no you know
it's always been a good a good place you
know didn't get to partake in the
festivities well you like drinking milk
more than anything else I'm sure Scott
that's the bit that's the best tasting
hey congratulations on winning your
fifth and you know and being part of
team Honda thanks Scott thank you so
much I really appreciate being on thank
you always thanks for coming on Scott
Dixon nine is the Twitter account right
there the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience
you